and if the U.S does default the
President says it won't be because of
him
the merits based on what I've offered I
would be blameless on the politics of it
no won't be blameless I think there are
some
Maggie Republicans in the house
who know the damage that it would do to
the economy
and because I am president and
president's responsible for everything
Biden would take the blame and that's
the one way to make sure Biden's not
reelected
let's bring in Senator Roger Marshall
he's a republican of Kansas the
president did cancel part of his trip
which is probably smart because he
needed to get back here because this is
where the rubber hits wrote right Joe
Biden struggles walking and chewing gum
at the same time how about the name
calling going on how horrible is it to
be called a MAG of Republican right now
but we'll go on beyond that what the
president's right about is if we default
on our debt history books are going to
record that Joe Biden was the president
when we defaulted on her debt he's going
to be a one-term one paragraph in the
history book president he's going to go
down as the president the highest
inflation rates open borders Afghanistan
debacle and then a potentially a a
default on our debt I don't think that's
going to happen we'll figure it out what
are the people in Kansas
um you've got such a diverse group of
Industry there but especially I'm
thinking about the farmers they have to
be watching this pretty carefully
because this would affect them their
bottom line well what's impacting
Farmers right now is number one the
drought number two is interest rates
farmers are very highly leveraged so
when they have an operation loan that's
went from two percent to eight percent
because of Joe Biden economics and Joe
Biden inflation that's what's killing
them they're much more concerned about
the rain and the price of gas the price
of operation than they are this national
debt issue uh just do you think they'll
get a deal today not not today no I
think it's going to go into June
sometime June 1st is kind of an
imaginary line I don't think the real
negotiations even start happening until
June 1st okay both we'll keep paying
attention to that another topic here is
President Biden blamed the silly spy
balloon those are his words not mine for
derailing Communications with China and
he is seeing a shift in relations
shortly what do you think about the
administration's new attempt it seems to
sort of make nice with China wow so I
think this President doesn't even
realize when China and Russia Russia are
bullying him so so this spy balloon was
absolutely China bullying the United
States team well how would Joe Biden
react to this and they found out he
didn't do anything when's the last thing
time Joe Biden got anything right on
National Security and by the way our
open Southern borders the number one
immediate national security issue this
country is facing okay so to that point
you just got back from the border you
were there just before title 42 went
away there's a New York Times op-ed this
morning that claims this if you're out
if you're hearing about the Border
someone is trying to scare you going on
to say here's the truth if you it's
likely that somebody is trying to scare
you broadly speaking Republicans want
you to be scared of immigrants and
Democrats want you to be scared of
Republicans
journalistic malpractice so that's what
this is since title 42 ended there's
been 10 000 godaways come into this
country ten thousand God always we have
no idea who they are how many were
terrorists uh how many were criminals as
as well uh this is simply a lie I wish
that journalists would go talk to the
300 moms and dads who young adults are
going to die from fentanyl poisoning
today go talk to the hundreds of young
ladies I mean young that have been raped
on their Journey from Central America
here and now being sold into into sex
slavery I wish you would go visit the
Border herself and see that since Joe
Biden was sworn into office there's been
six million illegal crossings from our
border almost the size of it have they
done something right if the crossings
are down now after title 42 had expired
and that was expected to go up it has
the Biden Administration done something
right along the way yeah absolutely not
this is like saying Joe Biden's taking
credit for gasoline's only three and a
half dollars a gallon when it was up to
five so when President Trump was in
office they are averaging about a
thousand you legal border crossings
today this last week averaging over
three thousand plus a thousand godaways
it's those godaways that I'm concerned
about yeah and we don't talk about them
enough so I'm glad you brought it up all
right Roger Marshall great to have you
in town thank you for being here